hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled laboratory tests for
koban 19 this webinar is part of the
ongoing coronavirus virtual webinar
series produced by labyrinth
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask question box and clicks
then we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education press click on
the continuing education credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process Jochen accredits I now present
today's speaker dr. June woo dr. woo is
an associate professor in pathology as
well as vice director of Clinical
Laboratory Medicine Center at the
Shanghai General Hospital he is also a
youth member of Chinese society of
Laboratory Medicine as well as a member
of Shanghai Medical Association
molecular diagnostics branch and a
member of Chinese expert committee of
experimental medicine pathology bridge
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography table at the
top of your screen dr. Wu you may now
begin your presentation
hello everyone I'm Jill from Shanghai
hey how was your watching or later you
sure I don't that your food routine I
mean yeah it's a such honor to be
invited by a North American Chinese
Kinetico chemists Association to share
my thoughts and our feelings with
colleagues abroad on the laboratory
tests for 2019 normal coronavirus first
of all in order to better understand the
rationale of the methods used for
diagnosing the normal coronavirus in
China I want to briefly introduce the
epidemiology and by other biological
features of 2019 novel coronavirus so
this feature these pictures displayed
outbreak timeline for Kobe 19 on
December the 31st 2019 China allergic
w-h-o about several cases of our own
Amelia like illness in one city
the pneumonia like illness was named
Kobe 19 by whu-oh afterwards many of
those infected was were working at City
cities one and seafood hosts their
market hana - sugar mill words worth
noting that one and seafood wholesale
market also stowed live animals 7 days
later the passage in words identified as
a novel virus belonging to the corona
virus family and the words named 2019
normal corona virus since January the
11th the first test the first test in
wuhan from the novel coronavirus
outbreak was reported more than 18,000
people have been infected
including 3,000 local medical staff and
3,000 dead national-wide more than
40,000 medical staff from other province
gathered in Hebei province and most of
them went to local city
for treatment adherence out of the brick
so now coronavirus picking China is over
as Wuhan has no newly infected cases and
new new cases dropped to single digits
in China Menand but imported cases are
continued to climb but the overall
epidemic situation remains at a very low
level in China but other countries such
as Italy here in the spam report shop
arising copy 19 cases and it becomes a
global pandemic recently the impact of
2019 novel coronavirus and Sabah has
surpassed 2002 us epidemic in China
and worldwide the the first genome
sequence of 2019 normal parole of iris
was performed by dr. jeong ujin's lab at
Fudan University its genome has about
29.9 KP so the final genetic Petri here
it's based on the nucleotide sequence of
complete genomes of coronaviruses 2019
novel coronavirus belongs to the
subfamily of Crona very ii here in a
family of Crona very d of the other
vital virus and it's suburb emily
includes four generals known as alpha
beta gamma and delta pro the viruses the
whole genome sequence identity of the
2019 novel coronavirus shares 96.2
similarity with one of the with one of
the baddest-ass related coronavirus
strings ah rit g third
that collected in Yunnan Province China
which did not list here but a more
distantly related to his cousin SAS
coronavirus about 79.6% similarity and
Merce Merce coronavirus about 50%
similarity so the 7 Crowther viruses
that came in fact people labeled in
either blue or red so there are 4 common
human coronaviruses 229 e63
which are IFAC rotavirus and OC 43 which
is a better crew Damaris and also HK u1
and better coronavirus and the three
other human coronaviruses MERS
coronavirus belongs to the better corona
virus that causes Middle East
respiratory syndrome or we call it MERS
Sask rotavirus the better also the
better the pro virus that causes severe
acute respiratory syndrome or Kostas SAS
pro the virus to the normal crowd a
virus that causes screwed on virus
disease 2019 or we call it kobe 19 our
list the receptor and the related
disease of each human coronaviruses here
star literature the fatality rate for
sass crow the virus is about 10% much
higher than that of 2019 novel
coronavirus which is 3% and is the
beginning of the break in Wuhan province
but recently some countries seem to have
much higher fatality rate anyway
initially the basic reproduction number
are not of 2019 novel coronavirus were
slightly higher than
[Music]
Sask rotavirus the person-to-person
transmission route of 2019 normal cruda
virus includes direct transmission such
as cough sneeze droplet inhalation
transmission and the contacted
transmission such as contact with auto
nasal and I mucous membranes and aerosol
transmission which occurs when the virus
chocolate job droplets mixed in the air
and the form aerosol and someone can be
infinitely the wind bracing it also be
transmitted through through the saliva
and fecal oral dissemination may also be
a potential person-to-person
transmission route coronavirus are
approximately 60 to 100 a 30 nanometer
its pyre it's a lipid bilayer that
enveloped viral typically in battery
glycoproteins are less protein the
memory protein and the available protein
the corona virus was named for their
chronic spike projected on the surface
inside the nuclear capitated
and protein forms complex with genomic
RNA interact with M protein during
transcription and assembly the SM E and
M proteins listed here
all structural proteins 2019 novel
coronavirus was reported to share the
same receptor which is a angiotensin
converting enzyme - or called as - with
SAS scrollbars by using the receptor
binding domain of the surface of the
surface spiked glycoprotein s protein to
engage se - but Daniel and its
colleagues reported that as two by two
the 2019 normal coronavirus as every
total man with about 15 nano more
authority which is turned to twenty fold
higher than as to binding to SAS world
of ours as protein due to a nominal acid
substitutions the genome of 2019 normal
croda virus is a single strain
positive-sense are a continual list of
six of arranged as of one a B as E and
from 5 prime to 3 prime with five prime
end cap structure and the three prime
and poly a tail the structure is similar
to a my the genomica is used as template
to direct translate poly protein while a
one-way and the YB which encodes
non-structural proteins as PS to form
replication transcription complex RTC in
a double memory vesicles subsequently a
nested set of sub genomic arrays or all
week order as G is synthesized by RTC in
a manner of discontinuous
transcription this minor strength as GRA
serve as a template for for the
production of sub genomic RA M is the
genome of the sub genomes of a typical
coronavirus
ten at least six offs the first off of
web AP about two-thirds of the whole
genome nests in code 16 non-structural
proteins except comma Crona virus the
next the first one other off on one
third of the genome near the three
terminals in code at least four main
structural proteins the spike proteins
as membrane proteins am available
proteins E and nuclear capsid and
proteins
besides it's four main structural
proteins different coronavirus in crows
special structure and accessory proteins
such as as GE proteins
3a and the pea protein and the for a and
the pea proteins or the structure and
accessory proteins are translated from
the SG is of Crona virus patient so it's
copy 19 may start out like with flu-like
symptoms including a favor dry cough
sore throat and shortness of breath and
so forth there are few patients have
little or no symptoms or called
asymptomatic infections but the older
patients and those with chronic medical
conditions may become severely ill and
even dying as inflammation of lungs
start to spread and in fact as a walk
vital organs like heart kidney liver and
so on causing multi-organ failure hands
was lab identified through a single cell
on a secret enter analysis the organs in
red
such as lung heart esophagus cleanly
bladder helium
level in red a higher ratio of s2
expression which is the receptor of the
s protein of crota virus indicating the
viability of 2019 novel coronavirus
infection
since it is hard to identify suspected
patients on their first visit to clinic
because the initial symptom of Kobe 19
are similar to flu or the common code
and and also the higher transmission
rate of the disease so the quick and
reliable methods such as nucleic acid
tests and immunological tests are widely
used in clinical laboratory for
screening out those people infected
nucleus in tests especially the
fluorescent PCR is considered as a gold
standard but for diagnosis of Cobra 19
but false negative results are not
uncommon professor Wang Qin professor
function he's a CAD emission of Chinese
Academy of Engineering in an interview
with CCTV the 5th February estimated
that the detection rate of nuclear acid
test
for positive patients was about 30 to 50
percent it means that half of the real
cover in 19 cases were worth missed and
in fact the patients could go unnoticed
which made the situation in Anaheim
even worse so the diagnosis and the
treatment program of 2019 new corona
virus pneumonia the trial faith paper
subversion now is a 7th edition and now
the 7th edition has been released this
is a fifth version by national health
and the medical Commission of China in
2020 allowed it cases only only in hebei
province to be diagnosed clinically
such as CT images showing
characteristics of why Tony
so our February thirteenth two thousand
twenty more than 13,000 new clinically
diagnosed cases would were abruptly
added to his total [ __ ] info bay leading
to a sharp uptick in total confirmed
cases Chinese society or Laboratory
Medicine published the expert consensus
our nuclear asset detection of 2019
normal coronavirus on Chinese Journal of
Laboratory Medicine is the early the
early february - correct - the doctors
and technicians in the epidemic areas
how to protect themselves during taking
samples from patients and the
transferring samples to the lab and also
how to handle different types of
specimens with extra care and how to and
how to improve the detection rate and I
think American CDC also has its own
guidelines so in the consensus the
principle for the safety are you need to
fully covered to protect yourself from
the virus level see here meaning
additional precautions including
personal protective equipment such as
protective clothing surgical masks the
face the face shield and other physical
barriers like the bastard so tests
include including nuclear asset tests
and even logical tests should be
performed at least in bsl-2 laboratory
the nasopharyngeal swap or ashram sputum
bath blood in the stool specimens are
suitable for PCR test so the specimens
should be sent to the lab the sooner the
better
but for long-distance delivery
you need to have pay those you need to
obtain those packing and the
transportation rules in China I think he
is also required in the US if it takes
too long during shipping for example
longer than 72 hours you need to put it
put your specimens at the manors 70 or
even lower temperature the blood samples
for the blood samples plasma need to be
separated from the whole plant before
transportation and storage the specimens
should be fully sealed in containers and
the labelling should be clear we deliver
to 11 for specimen processing step the
virus inactivation KP decorated the UK
decorated the nuclear asset of the 2019
normal crude Amar's
resulting the decrease of the CT value
and produced false negative results
especially for the low concentration
specimens also it is recommended to
Apple high automatic nucleic acid
extraction equipment using magnetic
piece to get the magazine maximum
nuclear see the recovery rate to
interpret the fluoresce in the PCR data
we need to refer to the manufacturer's
instructions here's just a wine example
for my example for the 2019 normal Crona
virus detection kids actually most the
detection case use the same strategy
that target two sites on 2019 novel
coronavirus genome one is off one IP of
under the other is on pin genes only the
city value of both sides are lower than
a lower than 37 we can conclude that
2019 normal Cromer's is detected many
steps that would affect the result of a
nucleic acid test but here I want to
stress the importance of the following
steps that often get overlooked first
the cause of disease should not be
ignored because it would become a great
disparity for viral load of different
specimen sources at different stages Yun
found that the viral load in throat and
sputum samples collected from the 80
patients at early stage F disease onset
was at a higher level and the viral load
in sputum is hard in the throat swabs so
analyzed the viral node in nasal and the
slow swabs obtained from 17 symptomatic
patients in relation to tales of of
onset of any symptoms higher viral loads
were detected after symptom onset which
is consistent with the yawns finding the
higher viral loads worth detected in
nose then in the throat conversely the
viral load in patients with suss
normally peaked at around 10 days after
searching the more transmission
positionality or patients with copy 19
then once with us and at the early stage
of onset they are also collected
different types of specimens from 2019
normal kronor bars confirmed cases and
those cases divided into three groups
based on the collection time including
the zero to seven days after onset and
eight to fourteen days after onset and
the longer time fifteen days after onset
groups they found at the early stage
after onset the lower respiratory tract
specimen the sputum has a hard edge
detection rated and needles wasps and
the strobe swaps is the worst specimen
sources for the critical patients the
lower respiratory tract specimens the
path to get higher polity of detection
rate here's 100 percent the pathway is
better than the sputum and the sputum is
better than the nasal swab and little
swamp is better than slow swaps for the
recovery stage they find that nasal
swabs much better than the throw swaps
so although both specimens it's
considered a very accurate it should be
obtained from severe nearness patients
receiving invasive mechanical
ventilation the deep the deep coughing
sputum is another recommend
recommendable specimen it should lower
the detection ability only during the
recovery stage or mildly
but also but still very still better
than the Soros walks but only 28% of
patients have sputum production but the
other had only dry coffee
secondly the performance evaluation of
nucleic acid amplification tests should
not be neglected especially for the
lower viral pollen samples
the South Korean research group the
South Korean research group compared the
primer and the proba sense for 2019 Lok
rotavirus that developed by cities in
China Germany Hong Kong Japan Thailand
and also USA the sequence of primary
probes sent for each countries are
different and different and as and
occasions at envira our genome I showed
here the China acidity suggested the of
one IP and the Germany uses our TRP SAS
are other happiest and for the all right
depending the eye polymerase and also
the eg the Hong Kong use HKU and and
work is here the HK u of 1p they're here
and US cities CDC uses the one and two
and three are Thailand user here W H
nickman Japan user
and this promise that they find that in
the case of targeting our DRP region is
raging the China of Yee said might be
the the most sensitive than the others
so the US and to industry and Japan and
to D this one this one this sets may be
recommended the for sensitive QR EPC is
a for a region so in the market the
China government also proved proved
seven detection kit with Flores in the
PCR method and the molding 100 related
to nuclear acid diagnostic products are
applying for the certification from
CAFTA meaning they are currently for
research use only oh and the colleagues
compared the detection performance of
different 2019 normal corona virus
nucleic acid detection kit and I find
that there are different differences in
detection ability of six of six 2019
novel coronavirus nucleic acid the
detection reagent for weakly positive
samples and their accuracy selectivity
and the reproductive ability of summary
agents are not good why is that the
firstly the amplification system are
different most most of the products and
two targets on its are a genome which
are of Y a B and E or pen genes but the
triple target genes detection kit or you
for target gene detection case also have
their market share problem probably
because they present better specificity
and the sensitivity
secondly among ten months during the
double targeted gene detection Kate
they have different sensitivity
according to their instruction sheets
the heart activity won the heart of the
thing one such as the ones that could
detect as low as 100 copies premiere
viral arm I could have by the advantage
our weekly quality of sample detection
Amina logic that has such as total
antibody a gem ITT tests are valuable
supplement to using as a test are early
and progressive stages which arbitrary
tests one opportunity set one to seven
days after onset the combination of
immunity tests with nuclear acid test
for Italy improved overall detection
rate of 2019 normal coronavirus
particularly for those patients with
negative PCR is out on late stage our
recovery stage antibody tests sebast
nucleus it tests genetic analysis
identified the mutations in 149 sites
across 100 of 3 2019 novel coronavirus
strange genomes signal similarity is
about 99.5% suggestion that the 2019
novel coronavirus genome is still stable
these virus
evolved into two major types designated
io and pass that are were defined by two
different
SNPs that allowed that showed nearly
completely linkage across the virus
during the sequence to to date this
analyze this analysis further supported
the idea that the two linked snps the
site here and here
adequately defined in the error and s
type of 2019 normal coronavirus the
mutation site of s and l of subtypes are
not common commonly used for 2019 novel
coronavirus
nucleic acid detection and the antigen
design normally we use M protein and s
protein for the antigen design so the
impact on nucleic acid test
immunological detection and you even the
taxing of 2019 novel coronavirus is
minimal lastly I want to discuss about
the circumstances that nuclear acid test
showed the virus infection again for
some discharged patients which is not
only happening in China but also found
in other countries such as Italy Spain
and Japan etc patients in China are
discharged after two negative nuclear
acid tests taking at least 24 hours
apart and indications of clinical
recovery including the resolution of
symptoms according to the new
coronavirus pneumonia diagnosis and a
treatment program trial version 7 which
is the latest version by national health
and medical Commission of China but the
land reported in JAMA they wrote the
artificial test tests or repeated five
to 13 days after hospital is
charge or discontinuation of parenting
our four patients and our positive all
patients had a three repeated rt-pcr
tests performed over the next four to
seven days and all positive so worrying
cases are will recover the Chrome
coronavirus patients in China testing
positive again for the infection have
raised questions among the talk first
about the criteria being used for
discharging people from hospital
so some Hospital I know in China have
adopted three negative results as
discharged standard but even so
currently there are still many cases
testing positive after patients being
discharged from hospital there would be
I think two possibility for these
circumstances so in China the nucleic
acid test of throw swab was used for
were used for evaluation the condition
of recovering patients however for those
patients in recovery stage positive rate
for viral nucleic acids in throw swaps
is much lower than nasal swab which I
showed in previous slide
who and colleagues reported in two of
three cases of Kobe 19 with with
respiratory tract infection and no
gastrointestinal symptoms the anal swab
specimens retained positive 6
and at least 14 days after virus turned
negative in the respiratory tract and in
the rest case the virus nucleic acid
turned negative
you know and laid over in job storks are
the same thing indicating that the
stories better specimen the middle range
or so
for evaluating the conditions of
recovering patients for you can acid
tests the similar findings also happened
which also happened on patients with SAS
program virus it is less likely that
just charged patients feel deal with
virus again but if a combination
patients especially the older patients
and the ones with chronic medical
conditions who did not build up enough
antibodies to develop immunity to the
virus
they will being high risk to get
infected again because the determent
virus by the antiviral the treatment
could create new symptoms after this
isolation there are two ways to settle
the issue I think the first way is
monitored 2019 novel coronavirus antigen
and the specific IgG levels patients
with detectable antigen or a low level
of itg should not should be retained in
isolation
the second the quarantine for 14 more
days after discharge okay
this is last slide I want to summarize
all those information for the early
stage of the disease or at the time of
hospital admission nasal swab thorough
swab and sputum sample are priorly
recommend for nucleic acid test you are
in the critical stage if nucleus a test
for nasal swab and this row swab have
negative results the sputum and the path
sample would be the best choice for
monitoring the patient's recovery suit
or or anal swab is proof a preferred in
order to
prove the detection rate antigens and
antibodies should the pretest alongside
the nucleic acid test for more
information about this table check out
this link it was a review I wrote for
Chinese Journal of Laboratory Medicine
last month
so that's it thank you thank you dr.
June woo we ran from it it hasn't
changed in as a reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you
have submitted via email following this
webinar we would also like to thank
laberd's for underwriting today's
educational webcast for we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we do not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through the end of this year 2020 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye